Father Marcus asked me to
to speak a little bit about
the icons of the nativity of the mother of God and
to be honest, I–
to be honest [laughing]
[unintelligible]
to be, to be honest, um
I felt like the icon of the nativity of the mother of God is quite straightforward
if you look at it
you pretty much can understand what is going on
and so I thought I'd rather want to
propose a few thoughts about the very feast
that we're celebrating.
The fact that our liturgical year starts with
this celebration of the birth
of the mother of God and then ends
with her falling asleep and, um…
It was great to hear the readings today,
and to hear this reading from Genesis
and this idea of the house of God
which reading that you heard, um
from Ezekiel, this closed gate
and also the proverb, the house of wisdom
and what should we see in the um
in the reading of the song
all that we're hearing about is
this notion of the sacred place
of this, this holy place
that is there, that is prepared
that is built
that is ready to receive the Lord.
In the book of Genesis we…
one of the things that happens at the Fall
is that God curses the Earth.
He curses the ground.
And in the Bible, the Old Testament
we see this idea that the ground is cursed
reappear in different ways.
And one of the ways in which
it appears is this image
of the barren woman
that we find in the Old Testament
over and over.
Sarah, Rachel,
we have this image of the barren woman.
So a lot of times, people
you know, especially Protestants
they wonder a lot about things like
the feast of the Nativity of the Mother of God
or these traditions that have been
gathered from extrabiblical material
to talk about the life of the mother of God
But once we understand
the pattern of scripture
and we see this image of the barren woman
we understand that this part
this notion, this story
of Saint Anne
this barren woman
who gives birth to the pure virgin
That's one of the stories
that is there from the beginning of scripture
and follows all the way through
into the New Testament.
One of the most
one of the most, um
One of the most, let's say
visible examples of that…
is when the Hebrews are in the desert
and they encounter the bitter waters.
They encounter these waters
that cannot—that you can't drink.
Bitterness is related to barrenness.
There's even another place
in the Old Testament
where a woman who's lost all her children
says "now call me Bitter
it has become my name".
This notion of waters that aren't useful
that can't—that aren't productive of life
and the encounter of those bitter waters
with the tree
is what produces the sweet waters.
What produces the pure waters.
So we hear it in the song
if you listen to the uh
if you listen to the choir sing
you heard it said
our very nature
God has healed
has set aside our barren nature
because this story
even the story of the liturgical year
we always have to remember
that it's talking about us!
That it's also talking about us.
Right? We are also that barren land.
We are also that barren woman.
And through prayer
through faith
is how we are called.
We're all called
to become the other woman.
We're all called to become
the pure woman.
So this transition that we see
in the story of St Anne
who gives birth to the virgin
That's the return into the garden
Moving out of the barren land
entering into that holy place
and that's why the mother of God
even in her story as a child
is always being related
to the holy place of the temple.
She's mending the veil of the temple.
She's secretly hidden in the holy place.
'Cause that's who she is!
She is that holy place.
And so,
even though we, like I said
if we understand the spirit of the scripture
and we see that pattern in the scripture
and we understand that
this transition from
the barren woman
that we've seen so many times
in the Old Testament
who gives birth to the pure woman
who then becomes the holy place
it is completely
It is, it is one of those fulfillments.
One of those places where
you see the whole puzzle of the Fall
and the problem that it brought about
fulfill itself in the life of
the mother of God
as she becomes the place of our Lord.
And so that is why
in the liturgical year we start
with that preparation.
We start with that opening up
of the gates
the top of the garden
this holy place
And that's, like I said, that's us.
That's what–we have to become that.
We have to prepare ourselves.
We have to, we have to, ah…
We have to build the house of God in our souls
so that we can have that encounter with our Lord.
And so, those are the—
that little thought that I wanted to, uh
to give you today.
Especially, and like I said
we live in North America
and we're surrounded by Bible-believing
Christians, um…
But once we, like I said
once we see that pattern in scripture
just how much it repeats itself
we can understand why the church has brought in
this extrabiblical tradition:
because it fits.
It's helping us see
what exactly this is all about.
What is this story about?
So, thank you for your time.